- All right.
Well, before we end our season premiere,
I wanna share one of the
most incredible stories
of the summer.
This is what I'm liking.
(lively upbeat music)
We all saw the devastating images
out of Eastern Kentucky this summer.
Thousands lost their
homes to historic flooding
with many clinging to their rooftops.
I've been through
Kentucky many, many times.
These are some of the best people.
So, it's no surprise that there were
countless heroes involved.
But, I wanna talk about one
in particular, Nathan Day,
a former coal miner, waded
into the rising water
and helped save nine people,
including five children.
And get this,
two of the nine were his
former school teachers.
We have Nathan joining us now
along with his wife, Krystal.
Thank y'all for joining us.
- Thank you for having us.
- Yeah, so, this is a
really important detail.
So, it was pitch black out,
nobody could see anything, right?
- No, probably scariest thing
I've ever done in my life.
- Yeah, I can't imagine.
Pitch black and wading through
water, you have no idea
how fast it's going, what's in it.
- Well, when I heard those kids screaming,
you know, I went to 'em.
- But during this time,
what he wasn't seeing
that I could see, was as he was getting
the children and the moms off the roof,
there was
cars.
What was like a little
small creek, it's a river,
a raging river now, and
there's cars going down
that's going, you know,
at least 50 miles an hour,
crashing into everything.
- That's what I'm saying, you have no idea
and it's black out, yeah.
- [Nick] Well, you couldn't
see the houses either.
- There was a lot of dangerous
stuff out there that, I mean,
we both could have been killed in.
But, could you live with yourself?
- And hearing those
screams and not helping.
- [Krystal] And hearing
children screaming.
- I'm just glad there's life.
You know, I'm just glad there's life.
(audience clapping)
- What a beautiful thing, though.
It wasn't just, y'all had the community,
you do find out the community you live in.
And I'm from a small town, so I get that.
You, you know, community,
you wrap yourself,
somebody needs help, you help them.
- [Nick] Unbelievable.
- You know, and I think that's incredible.
- [Nick] Our community
has been unbelievable.
- [Kelly] Hope is powerful.
Well, thank you so much for
being here, and thank you
for just being you and
having the hearts you have.
And thank you so much for your
accent, 'cause it's amazing.
And I love your accent so much.
- Oh Kelly, you are welcome.
I'm like, I could listen
to you talk all day long.
- Call me, we'll talk away.
- [Kelly] I'm liking
y'all's post right now.
(bell dings)
And that's not all,
our season long partner
Pilot Pen, makers of friction,
the go-to erasable pen of
The Kelly Clarkson Show,
want to celebrate those acting fearlessly,
obviously just like you.
So, they're giving you a thousand dollars.
(audience clapping)
And there's more.
I know there's a lot of
rebuilding that needs to happen
in Nathan and Krystal's community.
So, we are giving the eastern
Kentucky flood relief fund
$20,000.
(audience cheering and clapping)
And we're also encouraging
everyone at home
to make their own donation
to help relief efforts.
Visit our Insta Story to find out how.
You know, if you got, even
if it's a little bit of cash,
it doesn't have to be $20,000,
doesn't have to be $1000.
Anything you can donate
makes a big difference.